my name is lynette mara i'm a graduate
student at ucsf and today i'm
interviewing anita sill
who is a professor at ucsf and is also
an hhmi early career investigator and a
mother of two kids
and a black belt in taekwondo
tell me a little bit more about what
it's like to be an hhmi early career
investigator and how is that different
from
just being an hhmi investigator in
general
so the hhmi investigator program has
been around for a while and is generally
for
you know more established scientists so
a few years ago
hhmi decided that
especially with the
current state of funding that it would
be really that they could have a big
impact if they decided to fund
scientists at an earlier stage of their
career so they had their first
early career scientist competition in
around 2009 and selected 50 people
to be part of this program
it's a six year program
with graduated levels of funding that
increase over that six years
and
unlike the investigator
program it's not a renewable program but
it's designed to give people a real
boost at a time in their career that
could have a lot of impact for them
let's talk about um taekwondo what is
taekwondo all about and how did you get
into it
you know what was the training like yeah
those are great questions so
um form formally i think taekwondo
translates into something that means the
the way of the hand and the foot um and
it's a martial art it's a striking
martial art that involves um
uh you know kicking different types of
kicks
in my there are some different styles of
taekwondo and the in the one that i
learned
we also emphasized a lot of hand
techniques
and we used a sparring style that
included
both the hand techniques to the head as
well as
kicking techniques to the head and other
targets other body targets
and i really just you know i just fell
into taekwondo by accident really so
in the middle of graduate school i was
looking around for a different workout
and
i was a graduate student at ucsf and
here at
milbury union just across the street
from my lab
in the gym they were offering a
taekwondo class for some reason you know
stuck with it even though
i
you know i definitely didn't
definitely didn't get into it with the
idea of getting a black belt and in fact
if you had told me as a beginning
student that i would one day
earn a black belt and teach taekwondo i
would have laughed i mean i would have
not believed that that was
even remotely possible
but you know we had a very supportive
group of people
it was a ucsf studio so we had some
people from the community
but a lot of uh you know ucsf graduate
students and medical students and um so
i guess in some ways it was kind of an
environment of you know nerdy
20 to 40 year olds to begin with and you
know there wasn't it wasn't a
very um
testosterone driven
environment it was a very
it was it was definitely an ambitious
environment in the sense that people
wanted to push
students to
the maximum but in a
you know in in in a really positive kind
of way how do you even get from like
starting out to black belts i'm sure
it's a little bit different in different
dojos or studios in ours we had
we had belt tests that's probably fairly
common
in the taekwondo realm
so
there was kind of a progression of white
belt to yellow belt green belt blue belt
red belt and black belt
and
i think a lot of people made it from
white belt to sort of to green belt kind
of the intermediate stages but then
there were there was
so i think even for those people who
came in with a lot of natural talent at
some point in a martial art you get to a
you get to a stage where
you're going to have to put
a lot of work and effort in to move
beyond that comfort zone and learn to do
things that you
you know there's only so much that comes
naturally before you have to put some
amount of work in it so we tended to
lose people
at that stage for me it took six years
to go in between white belt and black
belt
for other people it was a shorter time
frame and for others it was longer
so you didn't necessarily know
especially as a beginning student when
the next belt test was going to be
because our belt tests were a long
affair so
let's say for an earlier belt you know
was maybe a minimum of you know a
four-hour
test up through black belt which is a
two-day test you can't
they're big time commitments from the
instructor's point of view so they
weren't just it was rarely just one
person um
testing you would get to know beforehand
when your belt test was going to be
which was really important i think
especially for the higher belts because
for me and
the two people from ucsf that i took my
black belt test with we
you know we trained for nine months
about 20 hours a week a lot of that
training together which is a real
which is a real bonding experience for
sure
so what are the tests like like
do you just like kick things or i don't
know what do they involve the nature of
the test is really defined by the
instructor
and i had a few different instructors
over the time that i was a taekwondo
student
but the person that i think had the most
influence on our tests um
was the instructor that i had for the
longest period of time that was
philip moore who's now a professor at
george washington university um
but he he was he is great at uh pushing
people to be the best that that they can
be in his general philosophy of testing
was
that um
if you if you push people to the point
of mental and physical exhaustion then
you can see what they are really capable
of doing
so you know if you're fresh you know
there's a you know there's a number of
kicks or techniques that of course you
can do well but if you really know how
to do them then you should be able to do
them
at the end of you know two days of
physical hardship i think was the idea
so our tests would include running we
would run sets of stairs there's there's
200 steps
between um kirkham and lawton street in
san francisco um on 15th avenue there's
a steep set of stairs outside so we'd
run to those stairs we'd have to run
there
um
you know holding like some of those big
you know exercise balls from the gym
we'd run sets of stairs we'd uh row
um
we'd of course do a lot of kicking
techniques and hand techniques
sparring is a component of belt tests we
do board breaks
you know
formal techniques where there are so the
taekwondo has um
specific forms or orcata where you do a
there's sort of a set of techniques it's
a group of techniques um that are that
you do together
um like a set of
kicks or hand techniques and they get
progressively more complicated as you
move up
and you know learn
different types of techniques
so you spoke a little bit about um how
to manage your schedule can you talk
about how you juggled all those things
yeah i think
i think the juggling is a challenge i i
always like smile internally when people
call it balance because it it doesn't
feel like balanced in any kind of way i
think a lot of it is
compartmentalizing different
um
you know different things at different
times so
you know when i have to make when i know
i'm going to have to go home and make
30 cupcakes because my son is
celebrating his birthday in class the
next day i don't worry about it when i'm
at work i'm like okay that's i'm going
to deal with that later and when one of
my kids is sick
and my husband's with them and i can't
be there and i'm at work
i don't you know i try not to think
about that either i basically have to
i think you know have to be very
organized and
focus on whatever is the task at hand
and get it done
there's a lot i think a lot of it is
figuring out
um how to be really efficient and
what types of things you know what can i
do when i'm tired
and do that then you know what do i have
to be really on the ball to get done and
you know sort of figure out times of the
day
when
you know that are that maximize my
productivity so do you see
a lot of parallels or connections
between your your training and your
scientific career i think they
definitely influenced each other
probably in ways that i didn't fully
appreciate at the time they're very
you know they're very similar journeys
where there's you know a big picture
goal at the end of it but to get there
you have to focus on the day-to-day and
lose some of the anxiety about whether
you know is this ultimately going to add
up to something am i ever going to
graduate you know am i ever going to get
this sidekick to work
you know and you just sort of
have some faith that at least
i'm going to give it the best that i can
and i'm going to take it one step at a
time
and
before you know it you've actually
gotten somewhere that you might not have
imagined you were capable of